hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to NOx time or what do you
got for me aim you were highly rated on
gamejolt but I've been alluded to before
on that alluded to uh disillusioned oh I
know that sound
but I won't judge I shan't not judge
until I see the full extent of your
brutality on my soul so show me whoa
who are you woah okay then you're a
little low res but I can see how you'd
be creepy I'll just back away slowly
alright someone buy me so what am I
supposed to do just go back and forth
until I find something I'm glad to see
you here who but okay am I just gonna be
walking back and forth in between two
rooms waiting for him to pop up behind
me like boo and then I go err whoa wait
a minute what the oh ho
you changed pardon you want to run that
by me again did someone fart down there
the only reason that's a little creepier
than I think it should be is cuz it kind
of mannequin asked and I don't like ya
Anakin's who's he gonna pop up next oh
hey that's the same rhombus it's got
longer all of a sudden again hey wha
what do you got now uh-oh
not sure what I walked up on let's go
good why are my legs so itchy all of a
sudden what is this game doing to me oh
my god my legs have never been it's here
than they are right now holy crap why my
head's itchy every part of me is gonna
get you I've often it's all my skin off
it's not like in one location is all
over God
why why they'd see legs this has never
happened to me before I'm losing my mind
markiplier and welcome to NOx timore
also I have some very good news I got
some sleep
raised with chica I soon found chica
whine whine whine whine whine